good morning millennials welcome back to
the toes tender happier I'm gonna do a
little Jazz scat version
Friday
all right that didn't work the way that
I wanted to do no happy Friday that the
podcast is skipping yeah
no seriously they are
they are you guys the podcast isn't
skipping the toast is here and it's
Friday finally the longest shortest week
of all time
you know what doesn't make sense this
week this week yeah no we need to put
this week behind us like we thought it
was gonna be something that it wasn't
so true like we kind of were Hoodwinked
yeah but now we know and we've learned
and we can move forward with these
lessons and we can do better we can do
better for next year and I think we're
also anxious to get the week over with
because of turdy Lou's birthday
so true so we can get this you know
really truly treacherous Milestone and
put it behind us no so we can enjoy the
festivities to the fullest turdy Lou is
29 and still growing up now facts
facts today is also more importantly not
to make everything about me so I won't
today is Olivia's birthday our eldest
sister our wisest sister our most
beautiful sister she doesn't even listen
to the podcast and she's taking like a
little vacation for her birthday so
she's certainly not supporting her
sisters while on vacation but on the off
chance that she sees this or hears this
sorry just hears today's Audio Only
um Olivia
happy birthday
to you
I want torture everyone with the whole
song but happy birthday Olivia we love
you we do love you and I actually think
she will listen today to see if we
talked about her
and her birthday I know this is like the
pot calling the kettle black but our
sisters are so self-involved like the
way they only listen to the podcast when
we talk about them like we're hilarious
we provide other value no but she loves
the show and she does watch when she has
the time so it's I don't have a bone to
pick with her quite like the snitch
the snitch who is so poised to be a
toaster yeah
it's like she's always has airpods and
she's always working she could do a
little like split screen toast she's
also like obsessed with pop culture
Olivia really isn't
so you're right like if Margo wasn't our
sister she would be a toaster and the
fact that she is our sister and she's
not like that's rude it is we
should launch another podcast like under
aliases yeah that's like still fire
flames same deal and watch how she would
listen
that is a really interesting proposition
and I'm extremely down for it let's do
all that work just to get our sister to
listen to us to notice us if you have a
little cyst like you know that's
actually the not the craziest idea
so true well happy birthday Olivia and
it's also speak now TV day
it is speak now TV day and what's so
interesting like if Olivia was a Swifty
she would be quaking as you know there's
so many numbers in you know Taylor Swift
is much like gamatria if you know what
that is
um there's so many numbers in the Taylor
Swift universe that have
important meaning
um in speak now there's a few numbers
that are dates ages you know that July
9th the beat of your heart July 9th is a
big day for this 50 Community
um the age 32 is a big day for the speak
now community so the fact that Olivia's
birthday is the day that speak now came
out comes out and she's 32 and still
growing up now she can't even appreciate
it I'm so jealous you should just like
write her a caption that I did like a
birthday caption for her to post
that encapsulates these things and just
be like by the way a free idea people
will love it if she listens to this
episode here's your caption Olivia 32
and still growing up now like that's the
lyric period that's the that's the
caption okay I love that
um do we have a story about we do we
have a story about the news that speak
now TV is making so we'll put all of our
thoughts into that so far all of our
thoughts and prayers I did not stay up
so I've been listening for like the last
20 25 minutes and what I don't like to
do is to listen to an album out of order
but I've been forced to do that so that
I could listen to like the key songs you
know the vaults the better than revenge
and my favorite song from the album Dear
John
oh okay so I went in the order of I
immediately went to better than revenge
then I went to last kiss to see if the
shaky breath was there spoiler alert it
was not what does that mean
so in last kiss on the first version of
speak now this now stolen version
um in the bridge is that what the fans
are calling the old versions The Stolen
version
yeah oh I didn't know that now it's
called like stolen version scooter
version like stolen it's SV STD exactly
um in the bridge of Last Kiss
um let me think exactly where it is it's
like Taylor Swift and she actually has
said
recently this week that last kiss is the
saddest song she's ever written and
she's so young when she's singing it on
the original track she's like clearly
there's like a lot of emotion in it and
in the bridge
um
she has this like really shaky breath
right before it's like really sad it
sounds like she's about to cry and
people were like I hope she recreates
the shaky breath it's a very small
detail that the Swifty Community became
obsessed with it goes like you guys
would never I hope the sun shines and
it's a beautiful day and something
reminds you you wish you had stayed you
can plan for a change in the weather and
time but I never planned on you changing
your mind
it wasn't like that I was just trying to
make the microphone pick up it's like
so and there was no shaky breath unless
kiss oh you know that is such a good
song yeah it's really one of her best I
was talking to the snatcher the other
day and she just like couldn't
possibly see where I was coming from and
I'm so happy for the Swifty community
and you know I feel like a lot of like
die hard Swift DC's days are younger
than yes yeah the olders but like when
speak now came out speak now stole
inversion I was 18. like Prime girlhood
you know all of those things and this
album is just like so much a part of
like my young adult life like Kristen
just texted me like about a memory from
us listening to speak now and I'm just
like the whole album is memories for me
and Margo was like it was for me too I'm
like you were 12. no by the way
facts you were 12. like who are
you kissing with your last kiss no I
just Mark okay now I know Margo and is
gonna listen to today's episode because
I have something crazy to say
Margo
is a huge Swifty and I don't want to D
you know delegitimize that I'm scared
but Margot became like an insane Swifty
like a few years ago like yeah let's
just call it what it is like I just want
to say like
even though like we clown on you because
you're not like as die-hard as us like
you and I were like in high school
listening like Margot like knew Taylor
Swift of course and like listened to a
lot of her music especially through us
but she became like staying up until
midnight type of girl like a few years
ago
a hundred percent I feel like she would
maybe admit that I mean who knows what
she used to do with like her password
secret journal but no but I remember
like the months when Margot like became
an activated Swifty like I remember
noticing and we were adults I was like
oh yes
recent history
yeah I want to say it might even be like
lover me oh no you know what maybe
reputation yeah but you're not gonna
like what I have to say and I honestly
don't know if I should even say it to
like start this episode on say this but
say it like you became an activated
Swifty in
recent memory and I would say reputation
okay ready ready I can rebut that's such
a lie first of all because uh where did
we go for my 21st birthday yeah we went
to the Taylor Swift concert because
that's like a fun thing to do for your
birthday no because I was a Die Hard 50
even in 1989 like I have been here I
have been here for an extremely long
time like I own all the albums like I
was listening and my iPod fan of her
music in the same way that I was but
like you didn't become like you know
activated Swifty staying up till
midnight like laying your life on the
line for Taylor
until I would say the reputation era
that's just such a lie like that's such
a lie
such a lie
okay like explain how I literally oh my
God no the way I used to stream well not
stream listen on a loop to Mary's song
Oh My My from debut like I was there
from the beginning you're always a fan
of her music like in the same way that I
was I would even accept that we were the
same level of fans of her music but I am
not an activated Swifty and that's a
road that you went down
I guess what would it be now like six
years ago
okay fine I'll allow the slander to to
assess that yes around 1989 I became
like demonic fine yeah and you like
started a Swifty a fan account and yeah
and you started participating in like
Swifty things
I was on like Tumblr Swifty like briefly
before that but okay fine sure that's
all I'm saying
sure what I was saying about Marga was
like you know what
I'm not getting into this because
Margaret's gonna be mad at me for like
you know trying to like be competitive
and saying that like I invented Taylor
Swift yeah anyways all I was saying is
you were 12 like who were you
kissing were you were 12.
I'm excited to listen to the whole album
relive the memories
I also am excited to dive into the story
where we talk about speak now because I
have like kind of a hot take I can't
wait to hear it I mean we could dilly
dally for a while which is always fun I
could but the story's like I do feel
like we need to get into speak now TV
the rest of the stories are really good
and then we're gonna recap Kardashians
with the fifth and final story because
we have some Kardashian news so and I
have a Notes app list of bullet points
that the things I want to talk about
while like Kardashians was an amazing
episode I actually had to write things
down for what I needed to remember
that's so exciting yeah
okay so if there's nothing else
if there's nothing else I think we could
get into the fast five stories that you
need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
Squarespace Squarespace is the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place and all on your
terms so there are so many fabulous
features that Squarespace offers
um one of the ones that I really like is
the ability to sell custom merch so you
can create passive income that engages
your audience and scales your brand you
also can create an online store using
Squarespace so you can sell your
products whatever you know if you have
an e-commerce business you're starting a
side hustle you can do that with a
Squarespace website they also really
flexible website templates so you can
get started with one of their
professional website templates with
designs for every category and use case
and then you can customize your look
update your content and add features to
fit your unique needs also they have the
ability to help you with email campaigns
which can really Drive sales and engage
your audience it's easily it's really
easy to collect email subscribers on
your website and then you can build
connections repeat business
Etc through regular email updates so if
you need a website for whatever it is
that you're doing in live Squarespace is
the place to go it is so easy to use and
we of course have a great deal for you
if you head to squarespace.com you'll
get a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com toast
and you'll save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain so
again that's squarespace.com toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain today's episode is
also brought to you by go macro in the
fight in the face of adversity and a
fight for survival against cancer Amelia
and her daughter took their love to the
kitchen and go macro was born now
they're spreading the power of a
balanced plant-based lifestyle across
the country with gomacro it's available
in 17 full-size mouth-watering flavors
like
um sorry and not like and they're also
organic vegan gluten-free kosher non-GMO
clean soy free which is fabulous they
are such good bars macro bars are made
from a combination of plant-based
ingredients that serve as a healthy and
delicious way to keep you energized
throughout the day if you have a food
allergy or a dietary restriction go
macro offers three delicious nut-free
flavors including oatmeal chocolate chip
maple sea salt and sunflower butter plus
chocolate and they have 10 certified
FODMAP friendly flavors so that everyone
can enjoy a delicious snack so whether
you're really particular or you have a
bunch of restrictions when it comes to
your diet there is a go macro bar for
you we have go macro bars in the studio
I feel like one of us always has it in
our purse it's just so great to have
because it keeps you full it's really
delicious and it's so good for you
um so you can elevate your snack game
this summer by going to gomacro.com and
if you use promo code toast you'll get
30 off plus free shipping on all orders
over fifty dollars just place the order
it's so good to have these bars in your
house like just keep them around you get
hungry if you're traveling it's just
like have a bar in your purse especially
these days flights I was going to
delayed canceled you never know where
you're gonna end up so have a go macro
bar in your purse and you can also get a
discount reminder when you go to
gomacro.com and use promo code toast
you'll get 30 off plus free shipping on
all orders over fifty dollars
or not thank you Claudia first story
speak now Taylor's version is here
headline news is that she has changed
the misogynistic lyrics on better than
revenge we all know in the original
track from 2010 she said she's not a
saint and she's not what you think she's
an actress whoa she's better known for
the things that she does on the mattress
whoa however for this version she
swapped out the latter part of the verse
with he was a moth to the flame she was
holding the matches whoa that was
terrible that was really off bed that
was oh my God okay wait hold on let me
do the whole lyric she's not a saint and
she's not what you think she's an
actress whoa
he was a moth to a flame she was holding
the matches whoa okay our girl is
struggling why is it so hard for me to
do that well I do want to say like this
lyric was leaked
um and I could not figure out like how
it fit into the iambic pentameter I was
like he and Mom and now when I heard it
it totally fits it is like a strange
lyric it's not it doesn't really fit in
my opinion but I'm just more so angry
that our girl changed the lyric and I
get it you know those were different
times like that's what we used to do we
used to just like shame other women and
we don't do that anymore especially
Taylor's you know a proud feminist like
I get it I'm so angry I'm so hurt I'm so
disappointed that this lyric is gone not
because I like crave shaming but
like my God who cares like it
was literally 10 years ago she hasn't
changed One Singular lyric on any of the
re-recordings and like I I get why she
did it but like come on it's such such
an iconic lyric also like these these
albums are like time capsules so like
her re-recording them and not changing a
single thing at first I was like oh this
is boring like these re-records but it's
actually it's what's it's what should be
done and it's what it's what's meant to
be done so that we can continue to
listen to all of our favorite you know
teenage songs
but you know there are Taylor's version
and they remain unchanged I I hate this
I can't lie I hate
yeah I understand where you're coming
from I also understand why she did it I
feel like it would be so incongruous to
who she is now to like double down on
the mattress dig yeah but they are time
capsules and I feel like it just sets
this precedent of like okay so now if I
have like a problem with any lyric like
is Taylor gonna change that for me right
right I'm just
I heard rumors about it but I'm like
there's no way because I remember when
we were talking about her first
re-release Fearless I thought maybe she
was gonna change a lyric
um to I think it's and that's the way I
loved you oh he talked wait he's close
to my mother and talks business with my
father and before we knew she wasn't
going to change anything ever in these
records I'm like I could see her
actually flipping those roles because
like women you know men business
whatever but she didn't so she's just
gonna set the precedent for like no
nothing changes yeah
but now and now something's changed now
the precedent has changed is what's
changed yeah I'm I'm not thrilled with
it and you know who I blame
who
Gloria Steinem I saw people on Twitter
are blaming Lena Dunham
her too yeah
I just uh
like it's okay not everything has to be
like perfect in PC like you can be
problematic when you were a teenager who
was angry about a girl who stole your
boyfriend like you're it's okay right
and also like this isn't gonna change
anything like that girl the actress
she's finished regardless Camilla Bell
go to her Instagram I went last night
the comments the swifties are deeply
unwell people are they mad at her
yeah like not you maybe has changed
better than revenge lyrics oh my God
they're not okay like literally that
girl's career was never the same after
this song never the same
um and not the swifties like victim
blaming no literally they're they're
wrong category they're wrong for that
wrong no 100 they're incredibly unwell
yeah
the damage is done is what it is you
know
what is the damage it's done so you
might as well you might as well
um
okay now let's talk about the album in
general here is my incredibly hot take
when okay so I remember with like
fearless and red when I listened to the
re-recording specifically which one came
first Fearless right yeah
um I remember feeling like kind of let
down when I first started listening to
the non-vault songs because I'm like
this sounds exactly the same and then
you know with a little perspective I was
like good these songs should sound the
same we want to be able to like stream
these feeling good but like being able
to have that element of nostalgia they
did not sound different at all yeah it's
like she's making a moment out of these
re-recordings but they're really just
meant to like replace the songs in your
playlist yes so that the Scooter's not
making the money yes so I expected the
same type of feeling am I the only one
who feels like speak now Taylor's
version sounds so different her voice is
clearly so mature but that really like
wasn't an issue for fearless and red and
and fearless was when she was even
younger so like I was like what is going
on and I just I don't know this one
didn't
it just feels it feels weird I can't
explain it like I haven't listened to
enough to say yes or no but snitch did
post like her favorite song in the world
is Long Live and she like said Long Live
was not long living that Taylor sounds
kind of angry and it's not as magical as
the original version and like certain
like very small subtle changes like on
how long she holds a note or she just
kind of changes the pitch a little bit
like she like was making changes on
speak now like why and I also felt like
I listened to better than revenge to
hear the new lyric and I felt like
it was almost like rushed a little bit I
feel like she was like rushing through
the lyrics like kind of like toss aways
yeah I don't know there's something uh
that feels off about speaking on TV
which I and I can't precisely put my
finger on it
huh
but I will say and why I always wait up
I wouldn't wait up till midnight to hear
the same songs I've heard 30 times I
wait up for the vault songs and
The Vault songs are really interesting I
think there's like five or six
um with Paramore well not Paramore Haley
Williams and Fall Out Boy and Ben was
listening with me and he loves that type
of music so we were listening together
he loved the Fall Out Boy one it's
called Electric Touch it's so like
rocker you know
um
and the Haley Williams one like kind of
flopped me and Ben were like this is so
not Paramore and it's not supposed to be
paramour because it's on Taylor's album
but like you would hope when two people
collab like they bring their energies I
don't know I really did not like the the
the Haley Williams one but and I don't
see enough people talking about when
Emma falls in love like that to me is a
pristine work of art and I think a lot
of people believe it to be about Emma
Stone and Andrew Garfield because I
think Emma and Taylor were like really
close during speak now era and that's
when she like fell in love with Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man Etc and it's really
like such a cute beautiful song and a
lot of the Vault songs are like
extremely long like four or five minutes
which I love a lot of the songs on this
album are long it was just like your
John did album less kisses like six
minutes yeah Dear John I think it's like
seven yeah
it's a long-winded album it's an amazing
album yeah I didn't listen to the
Paramore one yet but what is the
reasoning for collabing with Paramore
and Fallout Boy on this album like she
could do it with any artist like what is
the back story do you know
I don't know but I feel like the collabs
on um The Vault tracks are like symbolic
of where Taylor was at musically during
that time so like with you know Fearless
she had Keith Urban and maren Morris
like she was clearly doing a country
album with red she had Chris Stapleton
I think that's it
right yeah oh no yeah yeah
um I don't know what that means right
but with with this one like Taylor was
like growing up and a lot of the um
songs on speak now are like very Rockery
a little bit they like haunted and I
feel like that was like what Taylor was
listening to as like inspo during that
time like emo angsty yeah giving like
Secondhand Serenade energy you know do
you think if Panic at the Disco was
still together they would have gotten
that track no because Taylor's done like
a lot of like a big song with Brendon
Urie right but she loves him he's one of
her he's one of her guys
he is but they haven't like been
publicly linked in a while and I do
believe there was some like weird
accusations made about Brendon Urie so
maybe she's just like taking a step back
interesting it's impossible to keep up
yeah but I think people have been
begging for a Fallout Boy Taylor Swift
collab ever since they performed
together at the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show she came out and performed
let us keep lighting with them so then
another pretty angels subscribers from
tomorrow that I wish you could see that
you're the antidote to everything except
for me Wendy did she performed with them
was it during speak now times
it was or no was she like 1989 no oh yes
she's saying style hmm
okay oh no she's saying I Knew You Were
Trouble wait hold on she performed
at the
I Knew You Were Trouble what year 2013.
speak now came out when 2010. 2010.
yeah
so no
okay unrelated just a fun fact unrelated
yeah but I have to imagine that the
choices for collabs like is indicative
of where Taylor was at during that time
like what was she she inspired by yeah
while also being influenced by her today
because
she's not going to work with people that
she wouldn't stand by today yes so I've
only
listened to the Vault tracks like fully
twice it's literally been I've been
awake for two hours since Taylor to
speak now came out like give me a break
yeah no it's a lot everyone's like rate
your Vault tracks I'm like shut up
I know
that's the hard part about being in this
in the fandom I know the pressure now
because it gets to be too much
well it's an exciting day for swifties
and it'll be a fun weekend reliving I
mean nothing will ever be better than
like the red re-release that just maybe
because it was all too well 10 minute
version like it just gave me it was so
much I bet you think about me music
video there was so much given
yeah I mean I was like kind of hoping
for like a Dear John 10 minute version
you know I feel like she could go on
yeah yeah but I don't think she wants to
do that to John like that would do
exactly what
All Too Well 10 minute version did to
Jake because we got new new information
to be mad about
also have you seen that uh John Mayer is
like opening on tour for Ed Sheeran yeah
which feels like Taylor gave her
blessing no like I don't think Ed
Sheeran would go behind her back and do
that yeah
that's not so crazy to me that she would
be like moved on over it yeah
yeah
hopefully or maybe they'll get back
together
I was really hoping half of my heart
would be a vault song with featuring
John Mayer you know yeah that's like the
worst part of what John did to Taylor
like neither one of them ever
acknowledges the absolute Masterpiece
that they created together
wet into a bride with a paper ring
ooh Heaven my heart is the part of a man
who's never truly loved anything
so good so good so enjoy speak now this
weekend if anyone has any further
thoughts feel free to share please
please do including new turdy lou I will
I mean my God can I get some time
I know
everyone calm down we'll regroup on
Tuesday
I've only been here for two days
but it's also like a fun little birthday
treat for you it is it's it's treaty
Vibes and I feel like there's still more
surprises coming you know she doesn't
just release there's probably music
videos maybe at the concert maybe like
someone's coming out right right right
like Hayley Williams yeah boy yeah yeah
I would love that but she usually gives
people more time to learn her new songs
before she plays them like she released
hits different and played it like a few
weeks later she likes people to be able
to like chant the lyrics which I
wholeheartedly appreciate yeah but you
know if you're going to her next show
like they are on AC lyrics right now
study study study they are studying I'm
not they're pulling all-nighters yeah
our next story is the most random story
Victor webbing Yama who's uh oh yeah NBA
player claims Britney Spears grabbed him
from behind before his Securities
alleged assault so Britney Spears
alleged that she was slapped by a member
of the San Antonio Spurs security team
during an encounter with the NBA player
Victor webignyama candidly addressed the
situation in front of reporters he said
I saw the news I woke up to a couple
phone calls something did happen a
little bit when I was walking with some
of the security team to some restaurant
we were in a hall and there was a lot of
people so people were calling me
obviously he recalled hearing one person
call his name repeatedly but did not
stop after being told by security that
stopping would make a large crowd form
he said that person grabbed me from
behind I didn't see what happened
because I was walking straight and they
told me don't stop but that person
grabbed me from behind grabbed on my
shoulder she grabbed me from behind so I
just know that security pushed her away
I don't know okay I don't know with how
much force but security pushed her away
I didn't stop to look so I kept walking
and enjoyed a nice dinner he didn't know
that it was Britney Spears until a few
hours later I have like so many thoughts
and my first thought was like I cannot
hear the story about Victor webignyama
because Ben's best friend's name is
Victor weberman and I'm like what is
Victor doing in Vegas okay first of all
second of all I'm like why I was asking
man a thousand questions because I'm
like why the would Brittany know
like I never heard of this person I'm
like why would any why would Brittany
know who this random NBA player was and
that's like he's not random he's like
the next LeBron he's seven six he's like
so major I'm like okay that makes more
sense okay if like you're even remotely
into basketball you would know like I
know who LeBron James is you know so I
get that
now I don't understand why like anyone's
security would slap someone like I
understand like maybe shoving or like
holding them back but like a slap that's
like what you do to your sister when she
steals your jeans yeah but I feel like
it could be honestly it's giving like
Sheena and Markel it's like was it a
shove a slap an elbow there's a lot of
different ways to describe like the
forceful push of someone
yeah so I don't know that it's like a
slap across the face like you think
okay yeah I was I was thinking actually
more I was also thinking of Enterprise
reference when stassi backhanded Chris
and Dodie they were sitting next to each
other in that Booth yeah but like if you
took your if you palmed someone's like
shoulder and push them like it's out of
slap on the shoulder kind of
so I think it's just like the language
yeah and Britney's like so funny like
just going up to someone like you have
your own security why don't you like
arrange a meeting you know no it's such
she just got excited an odd story
it's incredibly bizarre
um I hope Britney's like okay
yeah
I don't know what to think here this is
just confusion Central like
and what I guess like I don't know who
doesn't recognize Britney Spears he
wasn't looking but also the security
guards you know I guess it's like on
them but still if they saw it's Britney
Spears they're gonna there's already a
crowd following him they're gonna stop
at everyone like bring Brittany into the
fold now it's not just like oh my God
it's Victor it's Britney too yeah yeah
yeah and Brittany was just like roaming
around these restaurants like kind of
unattended
the story is like just the more you
think about it it's like so it's so many
questions right and like Britney being a
very public figure herself would know
like if you're walking with security
like and you try to touch someone like
it's not going to go your way
yeah but she's Brittany so she's like No
One's Gonna touch me yeah
perhaps it's it's very bizarre it is I
hope that they can you know have a Repro
and Brittany can get her fangirl moment
her photo with Victor webignyama yeah
wishing everyone the best
agreed are you ready for our next story
mm-hmm
pump rule star Ariana Maddox will be
joining Dancing with the Stars next
season 32 this season on Dancing With
the Stars we are going absolutely mad
mad for Maddox said it's it's season 32
and still growing up now uh Derek Huff
said introducing her he said say goodbye
to the drama and hello to the dance
floor
uh this was like heavily speculated like
while the whole scannable thing was like
at its peak and then a few days ago
Derek Huff was at something about her
they were like filming some stuff so
they did not keep this a secret very
well and I feel like they actually
usually keep the Dancing with the Stars
cast like they keep that secret very
well yeah well who knows who the rest of
the cast is but I also feel like
sometimes they'd like to have like a
couple teasers to get you interested in
listening to who the other people are
yeah I don't watch Dancing with the
Stars especially after they moved off
cable
um so this is a quote for Ariana but
I don't know I feel like she's honestly
like more famous now than Dancing with
the Stars yeah but I still think it's
like probably a really cool experience
and a challenge I feel like everyone who
does it like comes out of it be like as
if they just like train for the Marines
and not in like true not in a dramatic
way like there's something about it
that's like extremely challenging for
people there's something about her
[Laughter]
I'm so curious who the rest of the cast
is going to be who her partner is going
to be maybe a love match
maybe a love match she has a boyfriend
right now and they're like yeah you know
loved up
yeah but I I just I just don't feel like
she should really be tied down because
like she's a season she's in her season
she's more famous than she's ever been
like maybe she could date someone like
famous yeah
wouldn't that be fun
yeah even just a little fling even just
a little fling
this is good for her I like this and
you're right people do always come off
of
Dancing with the Stars like they're
extremely fit always oh yeah and they've
got like injuries and bruises to prove
it no and it's like either you gut out
like week one two or three and you're
like oh my God you know I'm a Titan of
industry but that was the hardest thing
I've ever done yeah or you go till the
end and you are like extremely fit swole
six-pack like you're gonna do the
Olympics next yeah or like if you
literally had like four pounds to lose
they put you on the cover of People
magazine being like the Dancing with the
Stars I changed my life honestly I need
the Dancing with the Stars diet
honestly whenever I watch even one
second of Dancing With the Stars I'm
like I would never do this like
the way that their feet are bleeding and
they're up at that forlorn Studio like
at 6am every day until show day like
kill me no that's something I would do
that's like
you're up for the challenge I'm up for
the challenge and I think I would enjoy
it and then like the weight loss like
wouldn't hurt
neither would being called the star
neither would you know the platform
neither would the platform no it's not
on cable like I would still do it yeah
yeah prefer it on cable though
being in millions of homes but I'd
really do it for the weight loss
that's funny I would really do it for
the followers
yeah that's good too like the fame like
you like you there's a cult who watches
Dancing with the Stars and then they
come and like see you on tour and
like yeah that's what I want yeah yeah
I think it would be good for business
there's a lot of perks
having said that like if I ever got
offered like I would really have to
think about it you would have to do it
I know but like honestly I don't
think I could I think you could I think
you would be like one of those people
when you start talking about how you
surprised yourself and right no kind of
like pickleball you learned so much
about yourself and this has just been
like an amazing journey for you and
you're so grateful or I would take the
Lisa Vanderpump route and like fake an
illness so I could go home
I wouldn't let you I'd expose you I know
you wouldn't I know you would you would
do like a podcast expose I would like
get a video of you like walking totally
fine I'd be like she's fine walking to
the kitchen for a snack
and I would say I would expose you if
you quit LED or like look she's been
tampering with the competition what are
sisters for if not that to keep you
honest to hold you accountable literally
oh having said that please don't ask me
to come on no one is ask her
no please okay
well good luck to Ariana they're filming
Vanderpump worlds now so like I wonder
if they'll be crossed over not a huge
deal it's in LA but Tom Sandoval um is
filming they were like rumors but he is
filming yeah he had like a sit-down
combo with Schwartz at TomTom it looked
like
they also like I've been filming a lot
at Tom Tom and like Ariana went
yeah I mean that's the biz
yeah
I wonder if Tom Tom is suffering
well you know pump closed pump closed
but they're like funneling a lot of the
pump personnel and Tings into TomTom
yeah but
I never thought about what this would
mean for TomTom because Schwartz and
Sandy's is obviously like
taking it was like it was the biggest
hit right now yeah I don't know I feel
like it's a good question people
literally know that Tom and Tom are five
percent and they don't really see a
return from TomTom and it's more so like
a Hallmark of the show Vanderpump so I
feel like people can separate the two
but maybe it's time for a Rebrand yeah
perhaps that would be crazy
I don't think that it would happen
though because Lisa's like stood by them
and tomtom's got well for her yeah are
you ready for our next story yes ma'am
Tracy Chapman speaks out about Luke
combs's Fast Car Cover she says I'm
happy so this is actually a really great
story because Luke combs's cover of fast
car has hit number one on Billboard's
country AirPlay this week and
um it actually makes Tracy Chapman the
first black woman as the sole writer to
top the country AirPlay chart since it's
debut in 1990. yeah she told billboard I
never expected to find myself on the
country charts but I'm honored to be
there I'm happy for Luke and his success
and grateful that new fans have found
and embraced fast car on top of being
the first artist to drive fast car to a
number one spot he also earned number
two on the Billboard Hot 100 this week
where Tracy's original version of the
song peaked at number six
yes billboard estimated that Tracy has
already earned approximately half a
million dollars in publishing royalties
since his album dropped in March
wow I mean this the story of this song
in general is just like so impressive
how it's really become Timeless and like
a lot of DJs have done like remixes of
it like it really I feel like every few
years reaches like a new generation of
people and Luke Combs is obviously doing
his part for the song
um and it's such a gorgeous song and
it's a song that so many celebrities
have wanted to cover and for some reason
you know Tracy Chapman gave her blessing
to Luke Combs and I don't think maybe
she even really knew that it would do
all of this but this is just a fabulous
story yeah it is a really nice story I
also don't think it was like a single or
anything so it's just
it's having its moment having its Moment
Like genuine interest in Word of Mouth
not even like the machine pushing it
there it's just like right a great song
a great artist a Grassroots movement a
Grassroots movement even though I'm not
a part of the movement yeah I know
because you don't actually don't like
the the version but I but I love the
news that it's making like I love this I
love when you know something from 20 30
years ago like that already had its
shine like shines even brighter
yeah that happens a lot with Tick Tock
like these songs go viral do you know
the
um Kate Bush song Running up that hill
yeah you've told me about it and then
also stranger things or something yeah
like it's a song from maybe the 80s or
90s and it was like popular back then
and it literally hit like the Billboard
top 10 last year because kids on Tick
Tock discovered it he finally could and
then it was in yeah stranger things like
it's cool yeah it teaching the youth and
it's cool to be recognized again you
know yeah from like a whole new
generation of people that's called
timelessness and I feel that way all the
time it's like so many songs that came
out so long ago like are still so
amazing like they don't have to go in
the garbage can right we just like cycle
through music so quickly these days
so it's nice when we stop and you know
take a look back at where we came from
totally
beautiful
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
that's going to lead into the TV recap
that is brought to you by is that it
that is it it's going to lead into the
TV recap and it's brought to you by
Dreamland baby I want to introduce you
to a product that over half a million
parents including me use to help their
baby sleep the Dreamland baby waited
sleep sacks and swaddles it started with
Tara a mom who couldn't get her baby to
sleep she was exhausted frustrated and
searching for answers ain't that the
truth mamas her solution was to create a
gently weighted sleep sack that your
baby can safely wear to help them feel
calm fall asleep faster and stay asleep
longer so the award-winning doctor
approved dream weighted sleep sack is
the only sleep sack that features cover
com technology which is evenly
distributed weight from baby shoulders
to Toes that naturally reduces stress
allowing your little one to relax and
sleep soundly just like a weighted
blanket helps adults relax and sleep
soundly these gently weighted sleep
sacks will help your baby feel calm it's
very much like a hug a little Mother's
Love and your baby can do anything in
this sack that they can do in a
non-weighted sleep sack you know so if
your baby is standing they can do that
in the weighted sack no problem
so we love the Dreamland baby sleep sack
in our household sleep sacks have solved
so many nighttime things for us and I
would totally recommend it to New mamas
who have tried everything and it's just
you know sleep full nights are not are
just not happening for them right now
the best news is that they're offering
an exclusive discount to the toast
listeners just head to
dreamlandbabyco.com Pages slash toast
and use code toast at checkout to get 20
off and put your sleepless nights to
rest because when baby sleeps good Mama
sleeps better
today's episode is also brought to you
by betterhelp sometimes in life we're
faced with tough choices and the path
forward isn't always clear so whether
you're dealing with decisions around
your career your relationships or
anything else therapy helps you stay
connected to what you really want while
you navigate life so you can move
forward with confidence and excitement
trusting yourself to make the right
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets and better help is an
amazing resource if you've been thinking
about starting therapy why don't you
give better help a try the best part of
better help is that it's done entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists at any time
for no charge you know life is so crazy
sometimes it's nice to just settle down
we move so quickly take an hour once a
week whatever you're comfortable with
and just slow down and figure out how
you can be the best version of you so
you can be the best version you know for
other people so what I love about
betterhelp is that because it's done
entirely online it's really accessible
and a lot of like the awkward social
interactions that are included with
in-person therapy are eliminated here so
you can do video chat you can do text
you can do phone call whatever medium is
easiest and makes you most comfortable
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com toast today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t never there's never a bad time
to take charge of your mental health and
better help is always there for you so
betterhelp.com toast will get you 10 off
your first month and you won't regret it
truly you won't thanks Claude you're
welcome
our fifth and final story new skim swim
campaign Stars Jenny McCarthy and Carmen
Electra they're reuniting for the new
sexy campaign the 90s icons Post in skim
swimwear and a shoot that captures the
sizzling heat of the summer and also
like the sizzling heat of these 90s
icons no and these bodies oh my God
bodies so they look amazing they look
amazing I literally would like had to
like re-watch it because I was like was
this shot today they look so unreal
they're like rocking mods and it's just
giving the energy of the 90s and skims
always does really topical campaigns um
yeah but this to me just like hit
different the former MTV icons and dirty
love co-stars have reunited in a shoot
that captures the sexiness and fun of
Summer and the women's agelessness
in the just released photos they pose
together watching a sports car holding
electric guitars and eating ice cream
all while in skim swimwear it was also
giving like Carl's Jr
yes by the way that's an amazing call um
I was also like confused everyone was
like these two are reuniting I'm like
what were they on together like I didn't
know that they had a thing together what
was it you just said MTV girls and dirty
love co-stars I don't know what that is
yeah but I've never heard of dirty love
like I feel like it would be like
Melrose Place or something like no by
the way I was like were these two on
Beverly Hills 90210 or like I watch it's
giving Carl's Jr I also just want to say
like something I so appreciate about
skims is like they really do the most to
be like incredibly inclusive without
sacrificing like the glamorousness I
feel like when when Brands want to be
relatable they have like you know models
with no makeup and like yeah why did why
why why does it have to be inclusive and
lose that element of like fabulousness
it's like so real so
ugly and hairy and smelly yeah like what
is that and I feel like this games does
such a good job of being like gender
include um gender inclusive size
inclusive age inclusive race inclusive
and it's like it's not giving like that
Corning inclusive Vibe you know what I
mean yes totally but then when you think
on it it's like oh yeah I guess these
women like wouldn't have been tapped for
a no bathing suit campaign right now but
like I'm glad they were
right like I think that's such an under
appreciated
um element of the brand where it's like
in this day and age people you know will
have these campaigns that like check
certain boxes but I don't know but it
doesn't make me feel like fabulous but I
feel like with every single skin as one
I feel like she just did the Ice spice
one and then she had like the Victoria's
Secret which like sounds like not
inclusive but these are like 50 year old
women like yeah it really it it slaps
every time major Kudos I cannot say
enough about skims as a brand oh and
that was like a rant I was gonna go on
yesterday but I remember I didn't skims
is like literally
huge
you know I feel like they're bigger than
Spanx like in terms of shapewear
I feel like not even in terms of shape
wear but just in terms of
um undergarments and things like yeah
like if I wanted you know fresh undies
or fresh bralettes or something like I
would go to skims and I guess if I was
getting a wanted to get like a pair of
control top shorts I don't know
I guess I would go to skims now because
I have so many pairs that I love but I
feel like they just like totally
captured like the loungewear category
and like Essentials yeah and now I found
myself like if I need
undergarments girdles whatever I totally
go to Spanx I mean excuse me skims if I
need clothes these days I go to Spanx
like Spanx really kills the clothing
game and Kim doesn't do Kim doesn't
really do um like outerwear or like
things you leave your house in it's
really like loungewear pajamas undies
bro I mean I'm wearing the skims
bralette right now yeah and Staples like
t-shirts
Staples right and how you know like how
you know a brand is like really like I
feel like it's such a next level like
billion dollar brand and how you know
that is I feel like the word skins has
become a word kind of has Spanx was like
are you wearing Spanx people say now I'm
wearing skims like it it almost becomes
ubiquitous not yet like Band-Aid but
kind of no I don't feel that way and I
actually feel like even though skins
like started as like a shapewear company
and a direct competitor to Spanx
and on its face like they are you know
at odds I actually I feel like Kim's
gone in like a totally different
direction where it's like I don't feel
like I have to choose between skims and
Spanx no I agree like I also think that
I own copious amounts of each I think
that's also due in part to like a very
clear directional change from Spanx
recently into making the best clothes
ever yeah
like when I think of Spanx I think of my
amazing pants I don't really think of
like shapewear anymore yeah
so everyone stays winning Sarah Blakely
and Kim totally they're both on the
Forbes Women's richest right right right
there's room for everyone
so true it's so true so let's talk about
Kardashians
yes let me pull up my notes full of
things I needed to talk about here
um okay so obviously the episode started
with like the bids the big sit down
between Kim and Courtney we didn't know
if we were gonna get it we got it and I
have to say we got it like I feel like
they did not just kind of scratch at the
surface they had like a really deep
conversation
um and there were a few things you know
you really put me on team Courtney
um after you offered just kind of like
your like her rebuttal yeah I wasn't
even necessarily team Courtney but I
could really see her side and just
understand how she felt and like I felt
like this wasn't like a um I felt like
this was a an actual conversation that
needed to be had not just like oh I'm
team Kim because I'm literally always
team Kim
even after not just on principle but
like she just I always agree with her
but this time I was like you know what
Courtney like is entitled
yeah so I went I went into it like
really seeing Courtney's side yeah but
you know that didn't really hold true
during the conversation and and it
wasn't necessarily because of like
things that were said but like first of
all like Courtney before she had the
conversation she was like I really don't
want to have this conversation with Kim
she's just gonna be like on her phone
the whole time and like literally
halfway through Courtney starts rolling
on her phone so I'm like okay okay I
thought that I literally had the same
thought but then she put her thumb down
pretty quickly maybe she just like had
to respond to a text like about her kids
like I felt like I could move it was
annoying and I was like oh wow she's
being a hypocrite but she wasn't like
scrolling mindlessly like she did
something on her phone and she put it
down like yes it was just it was funny
yeah given that she had made a point
maybe Kim picked up her phone at some
point but that didn't make the the edit
so what I thought was really interesting
is that I I think Kim made some fire
points but she didn't actually make them
to Courtney she made them in her
confessionals like we didn't know about
Andrea Bocelli and I didn't really even
put together that Kim also got married
in Italy so it's like they're going
they're having this conversation and the
more they're talking about it the more
stupid it is like they're talking about
Vibes and countries like you can't own a
Vibe and you can't own a country and you
know what Kim did make some good points
like no one's trying to infringe on your
identity like your identity is rocker
she's literally sitting there in a
hoodie with studs on it and like she's
trying to say her vibe that like she
owns Isla jolce Vita but it's like
actually not if if we're talking about
Vibes that people own
Courtney's is punk rock the whole
episode she's wearing like band T-shirts
that are like lime green and black and
if we're talking about Vibes Kim's is
like minimalist concrete you know and
spandex so I feel like Kim was actually
making some really good points just in
terms of like the nitty-gritty and then
when she started to make those points
Courtney was like okay but like we don't
need to like you know talk about the
details like once Kim started to like
make a little bit of sense and like
progress in her in her argument Courtney
was like okay but it's not about that
like and then she tried to like
psychoanalyze why Kim took this deal
trying to make it like deeper and make
Kim kind of feel bad for wanting success
and I thought Kim's response
where where Courtney was really trying
to come at it like as an angle to make
Kim sound like greedy or vapid or
materialistic no or no she was trying to
make him see or realize that like
there's something that she's trying to
fill inside of her like that she's not
um like she's always chasing something
it wasn't it stopped being about like
greed and just more so about like why
can't like there's a hole or something
like that that's what it sounded like
she wanted him to admit like there's
this Gap and you keep trying to fill it
with like more and more success
but I really felt like Kim's response to
that
was totally fair she's like I wanted to
challenge myself to do something that
like people have been telling me I can't
do and accomplish something and I
actually felt like At first maybe I
would have agreed with Courtney like
what is Kim you know searching for but
Kim's response made a lot of sense to me
and like it's okay to want to prove
people wrong and to accomplish things
and challenge yourself and I felt like
her answer was really good enough
yeah I agree I think people are just
inherently different like some people
are just like content with what they
have when they reach a certain point and
that's like a beautiful thing but that's
not that doesn't hold true for everyone
and some people like keep wanting like
to break new barriers and do new things
and challenge themselves and it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're like
running from something or they like are
incapable of being content like it's
just a personality difference and I do
think sometimes like people are running
from something and they don't want to go
home so they do the next thing and the
next thing the next thing I don't think
that's what it is for Kim I think she's
just someone who's like deeply ambitious
and I think she spent so many years kind
of like being the on everyone's
shoe yeah now that she's at the top
she's like I will not stop until I've
conquered everything so that every
person who doubted me can be proved
wrong right and I deeply respect that I
actually really do
um and it just felt like Courtney is
content and she was kind of you know
being like a little bit moral High
Ground high horse to Kim like who's not
content but I also think it's unfair for
her to say that because it's it's not
like Courtney gets these opportunities
and turns them down you know so she can
only speak from her experience which is
different than Kim's yeah but you see it
in the way that Courtney like approaches
business and stuff it's like she you
know kind of fell into push eventually
but she never like was like okay we have
to start a business like I have to
capitalize like everything she's done
has really been like a natural
progression of who she is and then like
an extension of her personal brand which
is lovely but that doesn't mean that it
has to be that way for everyone like
people are are allowed to be like be
more strategic and not just like I guess
they'll start a business today because
it feels like the right time and that's
not neither of those are better or worse
they're just different yeah and I just
felt like Courtney was being like really
judgmental
yeah but it also then became like this
is not about dng well and and it clearly
was not about dng because Kylie had the
exact same thing yeah and Courtney
wasn't upset like there was something
between Courtney and Kim there's
something that Courtney sees and Kim
that like she really doesn't like and so
every time Kim is kimming Courtney's
like well this is what I'm talking about
and it's like what is that deeper issue
I do not know yes that was my next note
when she said cut like Kim brought up
the fact that Kylie had this campaign
right after the wedding and you know you
didn't say anything and she's like yeah
well like Kylie's just in Kylie world
and then like Chris was a major factor
in this too but she held really no ill
will or didn't need to sit down with
Chris or Kylie like she was really only
mad at Kim thus proving that it's really
not about Dolce Gabbana like these two
just like do not see each other at all
like they do not get along there's like
this inherent I don't know what it is
but there's like a disconnect between
them and that's what they were saying
like we don't talk anymore we don't hang
out anymore and just because someone's
married and in a different place like
with a sister like does not mean that
the friendship is over fine I could see
how two friends would grow apart when
one of them starts you know in a totally
different place like you don't have that
much in common anymore but that's not a
thing with family no and she Courtney
said like I have time like Travis is in
the studio like it's not like I don't
have I'm in my bubble and I have no time
for anyone so it's just like what she's
choosing to do with her time also I feel
like when it came to Kylie and Chris
like
maybe it's just that Courtney has like
such high expectations for her
relationship with Kim they're 18 months
apart which I didn't even realize and
like the way that Kim Courtney and Chloe
are is different than how each of them
is with like Kendall and Kylie like
they're just like younger sisters and
there's less expectation and then also
it became clear in this episode that
like Courtney has like a lot of beef
with Chris I think she just like I think
she's just accepted that Chris is like
kind of a political animal and just is
always going to be business focused and
like like
almost like rank her children as it
relates to business and like that's just
who she is and I feel like maybe for
Courtney it's like
having grown up with Kim it's like I I
have higher expectations that you would
care more about yeah
but but for Kim it must be frustrating
because it's like selective outrage from
from Courtney yeah and you also can't
read people's minds like if she told her
about a dng collab and even though the
collab changed over the months that they
were doing it but like there was never a
big Outburst when she was doing the
initial Club it's like oh you you're
okay with me doing skim sex Dolce but
you're not okay with me doing a Kim
Dolce fashion show yeah and when
Courtney gets into the points like yeah
it was similar to her wedding and and
that was really personal to her and so
she's fair to feel that way but it's
like at what point is Kim supposed to
know like this court crosses Courtney's
line but this doesn't
knowing just the more they went into the
details about Dolce Gabbana and Vibes in
Italy and La delce Vita it really was so
stupid I'm like
okay and yeah
like it's a dumb fight but it's one of
those fights it's not about what they're
fighting about you know there's like a
bigger issue here between the two of
them yeah which they did not get to no
um but the episode like I thought it
would be boring after that because that
was like the big thing we were waiting
for but actually the episode was
fabulous like there were so many things
that happened
um first was Chris's birthday party
which I loved the girls looked so funny
North is so funny it was just great the
speech thing was hilarious like it was a
good it was a good episode everyone was
being funny and then why wasn't Kendall
dressed up
yes I feel like she was probably coming
from somewhere but from a shoot throw
away gone like not all of you have to be
in Glam for five hours just like put a
wig on and like wear Chris's pajamas
like yeah that was weird it was who's
the only one and Kathy Hilson
of course Kathy Hilton I loved just
getting a small glimpse of Queen Kathy
yeah but it was a really nice uh
birthday chair yeah and it was
interesting how everyone was talking
about like how weird not weird or how
nice it was that Courtney threw it like
they were shocked yeah I guess they
don't have like the greatest
relationship yeah
interesting mm-hmm
um and then Kim showed us her Malibu
house or what will be her Malibu house
that was like a little boring
um
but happy for her yeah and then the
Kanye stuff which I didn't know that
they were gonna address at all this
season as directly as they did
um which I appreciated I don't I'm not
one of those people who feels the need
for like Kim to speak up every time
Kanye does something crazy I think
that's in like an extremely unreasonable
thing to ask of someone
um but I did find it interesting to hear
what she said and to be honest I thought
the most interesting part when she was
having that breakdown was when Chloe
opened up and she was like you don't
think I feel bad about Lamar like I that
honestly that part like made me tear up
like how they just take on other
people's and doing themselves yeah
as much as like they addressed it they
didn't really talk about anything
specific but I think that's the inherent
uh conflict that Kim has with herself
it's like she has so much that she wants
to say I'm sure but she every time she
goes to say something she's always going
to think of her kids first and so she's
not going to say anything so even you
know when it when it was happening like
on Twitter she said as little as she
possibly could because I guess people
were demanding that she say something
and I totally like I don't know who was
making those demands like but it was
unnecessary yeah and then even on the
show it's like okay we're gonna talk
about on the show because this is our
platform but still at the end of the day
like I'm gonna put my kids first and so
I'm really not gonna say anything other
than like I'm feeling internal conflict
but when you listen to the conversation
like she just kept saying like I feel so
bad like I'm so I'm having such a hard
time and like she didn't explain like
why she felt bad or what's harder like
what what her like personal internal
thoughts are about it because she's not
gonna speak ill of the father her
children which I totally respect and so
it's like as much as you want answers
for from Kim like she's always she
probably like goes does the mantle
gymnastics and then it's like but the
kids and then everything else falls to
the Wayside yeah but I did think it was
really interesting and I think she's
getting some backlash for saying like
once she posted something in support of
the Jewish Community then it was like
you know everything else fell then
Adidas dropped him and she felt really
bad about that
um and I think she's just getting some
like for that but I I weirdly
understand what she meant
um because this is the father of her
children and and no matter what they do
you don't want them to
um fail even if they deserve it because
that's you know who your kids look up to
and that's who's going to take care of
your kids if anything happens to you so
like
I I understand how it sounded weird but
I weirdly understood what she meant yeah
and also just like the way I remember it
I feel like that's not what happened but
I can imagine no but for her it felt
that way but in real life it had nothing
to do with Kim posting yeah yeah yeah no
I agree
so
it's just like a really hard spot for
her to be in I thought it was a great
episode honestly
yeah it was good like there was um
it was good yeah
um I thought this was a great episode
always went into the swirlies the last
episode with Claudia being
this one
yeah so there is no episode on Monday
because it's my birthday so make sure to
wish me happy birthday and we're
back on Tuesday I hope you enjoyed the
show thank you so much for listening to
the channels on Monday Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
you need to remember Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available
[Music]
standing and wickedly talented we are I
hope you guys have an amazing weekend
and we'll see you on Tuesday
love ya bye